？？？：はじめさん
はい
？？？：あのーおにぎりって知ってます？
はじめ：おにぎり？
？？？：おにぎり
はじめ：名前だけは聞いたことがあります
？？？：あー名前だけ
？？？：あのね、おにぎっていうのは
？？？：お米を手で握って
？？？：それを海苔で包んでね
？？？：三角とか丸とかあって
？？？：中に自分の好きな具を入れて食べるっていう物なんだけど
？？？：食べたい？
はじめ：まあ食べたいっすね
というわけで”おにぎり”でございます
？？？：そのおにぎりなんですけど
？？？：巷だと噂がたっておりまして
30秒で食べれないっていう噂がたっていて
はじめ：30秒で食えないの？
？？？：30秒で食いきれないっていう噂がたっていて
はじめ：え、絶対？
？？？：ほぼほぼ食べれないんじゃないかっていう
はじめ：うーそでしょ
？？？：そう思ってたんですよ私も
はじめ：やったんすか？
？？？：やりました
はじめ：食えたの？
？？？：ダメでしたね
？？？：是非やっていただきたいなと思って
はじめ：あーいいだろう
はじめ：30秒でしょ？
？？？：30秒です
はじめ：バカ野郎バカ野郎お前バカ野郎
今回はですねコンビニのおにぎりが30秒で食べきれない説
が浮上しております
なので今日はね
ちと軽くねまだ夜ご飯も食ってないんでね
30秒でぱくっと食っちゃいたいと思います
はじめ：え、どっちでもいいんでしょ？
？？？：多分ね
はじめ：普通にじゃあ海苔はちょっとあれなんで
はじめ：普通にじゃあこっちからいきます
まずは、わかめごはんからいきます
？？？：口に入れてから飲み込むまで30秒
はじめ：飲み込んだ時点の30秒ですね
？？？：そう、飲み込むまでの30秒
ちなみに髪の毛染めました
ありがとうございます
START
あ、いけるわ
はじめ：もう終わったの？
今度は海苔バージョンでいってみようと思います
はじめ：なんか今、俺の作戦で
はじめ：たくさん口に含んだら
時間ロスだから
ちまちま食う作戦でいきます
よしこいや！
？？？：よしじゃあ行くゾ
3 2 1
START
はじめ：あ、海苔しか食えねー
10秒経過
20秒経過
残り5秒
おええ～
喉詰まったら本当に危ないから
できればやめといてください
やるとしても無理に飲み込まないようにしてください
ただ本当に飲み込めませんでした
See you next time